obrigada a estar aqui presente e
apresentação já começou em que eu
cobrasse graças a abrir 3 eo vamos falar
que o carinho do universo do céu e o que
isto se avista terra
o nosso sol eu crio estrela que evita na
nossa numa galáxia muito parecida com
esta vocês vão ver
e só não está sozinho existem planetas
têm os vizinhos à sua volta são os
planetas de nosso planeta é realmente o
planeta muito especial é o único nós
sabemos até hoje que tem verdadeiramente
vida e realmente esse planeta tem uma
visão fantástica vista do espaço é um
pequeno ponto azul rodeado por um céu
negro fundo e vocês já tiraram será que
será que de terra o céu também é assim
tão negro
infelizmente não
durante o dia muito por causa da
atmosfera
quando anoitece só que quando anoiteceu
é realmente negro como vimos aquela
imagem
infelizmente os elétrons por construímos
porque graças à poluição luminosa das
grandes viradas como lisboa
nós não conseguimos ter a obsessão das
estrelas por muitas delas são apagadas
dvds chefe luz
o que acontece é que infelizmente astros
ainda muito com brilho muito intenso
como algumas estrelas e planetas e as
estrelas e planetas e conseguem ser
visíveis das grandes cidades como lisboa
por exemplo a lua é uma é um dos astros
que pode ser visto nas suas diversas
fases e ao longo a onu ali em diferentes
posições diferentes horas nós também
temos algumas algumas estrelas mais
brilhantes e alguns planetas como vênus
marte e júpiter
o ets turno mas ainda um outro objeto
que visível aqui da terra e que se
calhar vocês não fazem idéia que estes
são espacial internacional
a sessão especial internacional é vista
como uma pequena estrela de prefixos que
que passa e vai se movendo devagarinho
ao longo do céu
descrevendo uma fotografia um rasto de
luz como vocês podem ver essa imagem mas
na realidade ela aparenta ser uma
estrela mas na realidade não mostrou
qualquer porque existiam há seres
humanos dentro existem novos astronautas
que fazem experiências científicas agora
que tem uma visão única e fascinante da
nossa terra e como é que está aqui é o
nosso o nosso país visto do espaço é
realmente uma visão impressionante mas
também é porque existe o chez luz como
vocês vêem essa luz é disponibilizada e
é projetada para o espaço e se essa
imagem estava a mostrar aqui bastante
ofensivo é por isso e vierem que podem
ver portugal e espanha
a nossa cidade é igual e com um brilho
muito intenso e por isso nós também
devemos lutar e tira a tensão realmente
porque e por causa disto brito não sirvo
que os trotes é que os stones aqui em
terra precisam subir muito alto precisa
de pontos acima das nuvens para que
assim possam ter uma visão em parte do
universo e possam realmente ter acesso
ao estudo de de muitos objetos celestes
como glosas galáxias muito distantes
através dos grandes telescópios que tem
é é no qual tem a oportunidade de
trabalhar
vocês têm aí que dois terços da
população mundial nunca viu a via láctea
provavelmente eu acho que nenhum de
vocês viu já alguém viu láctea no céu
só que infelizmente no brasil ainda são
muito novos itens dessa certeza que terá
o final de viver a dois é de cerca de 5
milhões de pessoas que nunca viram é via
láctea é existem muitas pessoas que
fazem isso por paixão souza o chamado
astrônomos amadores mas também muitos
entusiastas existem milhões do
ministério e são eles que muitas vezes
também colaboram com os profissionais e
ajudam a descobrir novos asteroides
cometas
supernovas e te planetas extra solares
estão muito longe
outras estrelas orbitando outras
estrelas é que não fazem parte
importante do nosso sistema solar graça
e um clipe para combater este problema
que foi criado a primeira reserva é
reserva dark sky ao quebrar o nosso
intenso e essa reserva é realmente é
muito especial
tal como vocês são o que os presidentes
porque foi o primeiro sítio muito
estendido como estar lá e talvez
destination significa que o sítio tem as
condições ideais para os turistas
poderão observar o céu o seu realmente
só os nossos antepassados tinham acesso
wando uma eficiência e que o espetáculo
que poderá observar o universo e poderá
observar a via láctea revelar que a
nossa própria galáxia que é visível aqui
de terra é que vocês vêem um braço da
nossa galáxia
tal como essa imagem mostra e foi que eu
estava aqui foi captado num intenso no
entanto é também um sítio especial
permite por exemplo no encanto da noite
poder entrar em contato em comunhão
financeiramente com a natureza à luz do
luar por exemplo o além disso poder por
exemplo encontrar é uma estrela muito
especial também a estrela popular em
torno das estrelas desses traços todos
luz encontra se um ponto fixo
aparentemente fixo como se tivesse
parado no tempo é realmente estranho
popular que indica o norte e que no
último biênio está em ajudado aguiar em
direção ao norte do estado encontrar o
nosso caminho e também esta visão
impressionante universo que que nos
submete para para nós em ciência mais
pura para que realmente é importante
é muito importante percebermos que no
fundo todos nós partilhamos um mixhell
em tudo em tudo nosso planeta
empreendimento você cor da voz de hélder
da política da posição social acima de
tudo isso nós todos temos algo em comum
temos realmente é a partir do universo
sem fronteiras e é isso que no fundo eu
explico também fizessem porque a 100
esta é esse espetáculo da natureza e
tentar se preservar este este é
fantástico é que nós temos acesso porque
na realidade esta janela que nós temos
aqui da terra é uma janela para o
universo para o nosso universo onde nós
próprios
evitamos e onde nos encontramos num belo
pontos o chamado planeta terra
obrigado